- Wet roll, ketchup,
double dog. [Burping]
Ignore the mountain of bread.
Hello, everyone.
I am Jack Settleman, two-time
champion of the Punishment League,
but unfortunately, in
Week 4, I am the loser.
Russell Wilson—he played well.
Everyone wanted Derrick Henry
against the Jets. Davante Adams—Mr.
Touchdown, every single week last year.
So, I pay up for Davante Adams.
And who scores two touchdowns?
Randall freaking Cobb.
But, what pains me even
more than that, I spent
$49,900.
I was $100 away
from upgrading Adams to
Tyreek Hill, and I didn't do it.
And now, I have to attempt
to eat 20 hot dogs in 20 minutes.
It's time to punish myself.
Oh, no.
The bread is going to be the
hardest part. Ah, that’s disgusting.
One down. So, Joey Chestnut.
eats 74 of these in 10 minutes.
And I like hot dogs.
We’re two down. I’m like, two
minutes in. I’m on pace.
I didn’t prep for the loneliness
that this will be. No
one is talking to me. I'm
essentially talking myself.
All right—three down.
It’s kinda easy.
What my mom always told me,
though: “Never fill up on bread.”
I kinda wanna do a double
glizzy shot here.
I'm not having fun.
I do have this in case of
emergency. I’ve done
about four-and-a-half, so far.
This is for you, Randall Cobb.
I didn’t like that.
Oh, let’s go, second wind.
The double glizzy has
been the best strategy.
I know all people, on the app
and on Instagram, will be like,
“Oh, you didn’t finish any bread.”
You finish the bread, then.
You do the challenge, all right?
I'm gonna go with some ketchup.
I know it's probably not strategic, but…
I don't even like ketchup that much.
The pile of hot dogs I have
to eat is not shrinking.
This is for you,
Will Dissly. Two catches?
Is there a way to make yourself burp?
Lemme look that up.
There we go. Yeah, I knew
that wasn't gonna go well.
Ten minutes down. A burp!
Five, eight, 10. I’ve only done
six hot dogs? What the heck?
[Phone ringing]
The Feds are on line one.
They said you can't eat
this many hot dogs.
So, if I finish this bite,
I’ll have seven down.
So, like, 11 minutes,
which is a good pace. I'm
proud of that pace. [Burping]
Oh, c’mon c’mon. [Burping]
Is anything else coming out
with that burp besides that?
C’mon, big burp.
[Burping] Mm.
Ugh, I can't even do it.
We're going back to
the double dog strat.
It’s the only way to do it.
Oh, now I’m just eating mustard.
This is one of the most vile
things I’ve ever experienced.
I really feel like I’m going to throw up
pretty soon, so...that’s exciting.
This is what I got left of the eighth one.
I can’t even get a whole thing down.
I think I might throw in the white towel soon.
This is No. 8. Shout out to Lamar Jackson,
He's No. 8,
he's the baby GOAT.
I'm the baby GOAT of eating hot dogs.
Eight hot dogs, 20 minutes.
You can't beat that.
No one watching this can beat that score.
Next Sunday, I will win the Punishment
League, because I never, ever,
am going through something
like this ever again.